hey guys i'm ryan right so it's
Valentine's Day happy Valentine's Day I
love you let's talk about what
everyone's really gonna be doing on
Valentine's Day watching Fifty Shades of
Grey I already got my tickets at
arclight sherman oaks at 1pm come me
either come then be there yeah so
today's video we're gonna watch 50 facts
about fifty shades of grey I have the
book right here handy dandy Veronica
read it it helped out a relationship in
a lot of ways i'll say that he's serious
I got through a hundred pages of that
book I'm having a hard time going
through another hundred it's just not as
interesting as I thought it would be
it's actually getting pretty bad
backlash right now well the movie is but
no the book I'm trying to like a hundred
pages in and I'm like you're like I
already knows every other sentence is
just about how Christian Grey is a
[ __ ] god and I'm like I get it get to
the [ __ ] already whatever let's
watch this this girl looks [ __ ] hot
movies with Meg that's my sister's name
she's not hot Veronica's hotter trust me
Veronica's hotter but she's pretty hot
this is made from today it will be close
to 50 facts about fifty shades of grey
that's a lot of friggin bags will die
rated
I'll start off nice and easy it's based
on the book the same name right by DL
James James his real name is Eric
Mitchell is the first book in a series
of three fifty shades darker fall by
fifty shades free James listen to sexy
by the black eyed peas while read in
sexy the series is based on Twilight fan
fiction in fiction has never come to the
bigs I knew I've annually Twilight
approaches the film rights 45 million
bucks the book sold more copies than the
davinci code and Harry Potter the
Deathly Hallows no water author JK
Rowling excuses to read it what a muggle
but over on the other hand is big man
anyway Wes library text and the book
what a text book shelf in Pennsylvania
there's a huge increase in sales of rope
duct tape and cable ties I always knew
those almond for pinky give it a kicky
these do combinations Commission citizen
agnosticism portable he's alone mouthful
fifteen to twenty percent of Americans
have enjoyed the pain of BDSM also the
USM my way home to over 2,000 sex club
time to turn up the heat something
Anarchy star Charlie Hunnam which
originally passes for humor and me sorry
I pitcher in Jeff naked let me for kami
Jordan uh dropped out autumn arrived to
character he visited a private sex
dungeon who was a bit really large haha
Arlen where he's a rugby player move
over Bieber there's a real Calvin Klein
model also the face of yellow to top it
off he was in a band don't get too
excited lady he's married his wife
Amelia Warner and it's welcome to
shorter less November forgotten
Anastasia Steele is play by Dakota
Johnson her parents are actors Nami
Griffith and Don
oh I don't blame you girl her
grandmother is after student entrance
starboard for the last three sets the
lucky actress who should have been me
and Jamie acted out the first and last
chapters of the book the code under
co-stars only excitation memorize their
lines impressive she's all tied up in
the weekends birthday music video
hashtags not take four also on the
soundtrack is Ellie Goulding hits on
love me like is even Queen Bey got in on
the action reporting an all new frontier
version of a phrase hands alone that's
featured in the first trailer is great
director meet Sam taylor-johnson
director of your boy which starter
husband Aaron taylor-johnson he makes
the cameo in the film they have two
children and yes she's a cougar in 23
years her junior oh wow yes she wasn't
in the mood to do a viral fact now for
the climax maybe will not appear fully
nude unfair said women everywhere also
not included the tamponski justice bear
calabar smells free writer of saving mr.
banks from strict but big action writer
mark bomback of dawn of the planet of
the apes and the wolverine punch it up
the film is rated R for unusual behavior
and broke Fandango records at the fact
of selling all rated film don't fret
curves and MGMT blu-ray is rumored now
in 50 minutes so be sure to be before
noon bonus fact isn't what the commies
find out they'll be a lot so much sag my
blowing crazy cause that bother you
whatever I Mexican anyways because
thanks for watching I hope it was as
good for you as it was for me don't
forget to see fifty shades of gray in
theaters februari 13
they hired a porn star for fan danger I
was like okay
it seems like you're about to that was
an interesting facts I don't think I
need to know most of them yeah la time
were just interesting I can't believe
this book sold more copies than the da
vinci code and harry potter especially
harry potter though heroin or is it
eight or no oh my god seven bucks hey
buddy you almost look like a total idiot
just now yeah the biggest [ __ ] idiot
you could look like at that momentum
Harry Potter is seven look there's only
has three is it all the books there's
just the one book oh that's a good
question it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter like either way that is [ __ ]
insane enemies harry potter and davinci
code have way more content than what
fifty shades are great look everyone
knows I want to see this movie not to
hate on it yeah it just looks like a
good time and sure I want to see some
sex wanna see some sexily guys pretty
odd there's nothing really unique about
the content that it surprises me that
the book would exceed that much think
about how many women there are in
America right now who are going through
a midlife crisis or their sex lives are
not that great because their husbands or
I work all the time and they're not
happy but they don't want to get a
divorce so they got a divorce so think
about all of these women that's like
that's like all of America just wanting
to feel something a guy sexually yeah
they want the perfect man that does not
exist exactly so it doesn't make sense
why they sold that many copies imagine
Oprah reading it battling mass children
I could totally imagine over reading
that a masturbating I don't wanna say
that cousin would have actually meet her
what do you mean Oprah if you're
watching this I've totally mastered by
chance where Adam I've totally
masturbated to you Oprah first black
chick I've ever masturbated to okay
sixth grade really someone had like an o
magazine in there oh she had an o going
on in her mouth you and I mean is
there's an increase in sales and rope
duct and table ties duct tape it doesn't
dog that also concerns me because I'm
like maybe there's been more murders did
anyone know like how do we know it's all
sexual yeah but no I mean if that's the
case I should totally read this book and
see like you know Veronica might be down
they some of the after one to get into
character he visited a private sex
dungeon which I didn't know you can do
that makes me want to see if I could be
the star of the sequel to 50 shades of
grey that would be a good excuse I would
if we got that written off his taxes
like how much it wants to go to the
private sector I'm Jen kazusa part of
his research it's pretty cool that you
can say [ __ ] like that like you went to
a private sex dungeon yeah yes it was
for research for because I'm an actor
okay yeah that's cool like the only
reason why I wanted to be like if you're
an actor actress best excuse in the
world to do whatever you [ __ ] you want
yeah Shia LaBeouf did that when he took
like acid yeah character yeah they
mentioned the tampon scene I've heard
other people mention it before but I've
never really wanted to know what
happened I kind of want to just read the
book read an excerpt from the tampon
team yeah I want to get to know I want
to read the book and get to the tampon
Singh and then if the tampon seems good
if it's the big [ __ ] I'd reenact I was
thinking of doing a fifty shades of gray
like having the audio book playing and I
would do a one-man show acting out what
the audiobook is saying but that would
be like a 20 hour video if you guys are
down it's how you thinking about home
video 20 hour long video a me just
acting out every line and body language
shifting if you guys would watch that I
will seriously do it I will break it up
into chapters for you ok I'll tweet that
like crazy it's rumored they're gonna
have an nc-17 rating [ __ ] awesome I
would love to see that if we get to see
his dick that's when you know you got an
nc-17 hardcore erotic film if you see
the guys dick and she has a vagina and
it's not [ __ ] hairy cuz hairy vaginas
are there because it's part of its
really hide it yeah that way you can
still get in
r rating okay yeah I'm pretty sure every
single girl wants to see his dick so
that needs to happen there's like no way
you can and I'm blu-ray it's like I
should do guys might think I'm like
weird for saying that but I'm like [ __ ]
you you only guys watch porn too like
most of that is the guy like dominating
them yeah you're watching it dick going
the whole time I want to [ __ ] see if
this guy lives up to the hype of
Christian Grey maybe that's why he's
dicks not in the movie because he has a
small wiener hence they shouldn't have
hired this actor that's why the other
guy was was a play him and backed out
I'm sure they did like it like let's see
your dick yeah I wish I was in that
casting room they said like fifteen to
twenty percent of people in America of
them BDSM I think it's interesting
because I've actually because I think we
live in LA and because of that I've
actually met a person as like live BDSM
shows and like in front of a whole
audience me she does torture and you
meet her and he's like you know like
they're just regular people who happen
to like sex this way it's really
interesting like they don't act
different they don't talk to there's not
like a specific personality about them
like they're yeah you know there's
people who have a sex life that's a
little bit strange thanks guys yeah we
just wanted to say happy valentine's day
and i'm sure a lot of you have already
seen 50 shades of grey now that it's out
so you tell us what you think about it
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out salamander Sally's channel we
just did a video on there yeah don't
know what it is yes yeah I'm gonna be
there in forty percent female okay this
channel has a 14-percent female
demographic according to youtube
analytics so whoever the female
subscribers are please comment let me
know who you are I only want female
subscribers to come to common towards me
do you know what's gonna be good guys
how about how about all the female
subscribers comment a heart so we know
that you're real okay come on yeah
and some boobie pics that i will not
look at cuz i'm in love i can look at
that bone and like describe them teeth
that would be okay it's like reading 50
shades great so yeah it's not cool if
you're like watching a [ __ ] but you
know if you're reading about someone
giving a very detailed [ __ ] it's
totally cool [ __ ] God you got that
covered yeah she got covered you know me